[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits we're two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time I'm link what is it not a
podcast
anymore I knew I wasn't saying something
right welcome to ear biscuits a podcast
I mean typically the podcast if you want
to change it I'm open I mean do we
really need to say that I mean if you
don't if you if if you need to be told
this is a podcast podcast I don't know
if uh let's go with it let's roll with
it if you're invited and I'm
R this week had the round table of dim
lighting uh I am going to be telling you
about a little experience I had
unexpected experience that I had this
weekend that I was fond of okay
recounting that to you and also uh
talking a little bit about this new
piece of
technology that I don't know how to feel
about yet we can process that together
okay and I
have the best party idea the best party
idea I experienced a certain type of
party
uhuh um and I want to tell you about it
shall we go there okay sure you want to
go to I think I know what you did I I
the way that things come to me
through your wife to my wife to me yeah
sometimes I know what you're doing based
on what your wife tells my wife it's
better that way it's like forth hand
information about you yeah
what did she tell you that we went to a
pie eating pie eating and contest party
yeah yeah well it wasn't a pie eating
contest right no it was a pie eating and
contest that's different than a pie
eating contest pie eating contest is how
fast you can eat the most amount of pie
huh that's not my idea of a good party
but nobody did that nobody did that it
was a pie baking contest R I've told you
and I'll tell you again pie eating and
contest it was a pie eating in contest
okay so it's a people were eating the
pies yep and then it was a contest yes
but it wasn't how much can you eat right
it's a pie eating and contest it's
literally what they like put on the RSVP
they called it a pie eating and contest
because I think that's what I've not to
give notes this early but that's
confusing I'm I've called it that like a
pie making contest you know a Pie
Contest well it was a pie eating and
contest party okay so that I have
arrived at being the best title for what
it was cuz we all showed up to eat pie
which there was a contest about what was
the best pie across two different
categories Savory and you guessed it
sweet wow Savory pies that's exciting
because no one ate dinner you get dinner
and you get dessert all in one go that's
right very smart and and then it's a
party so how many pies did you make for
it I made a grand total of two
pies are you taking responsibility for
the pies that my family brought two pies
okay all right and you know what I
here's what I actually contributed okay
I brought Cool Whip and ready
whip
okay uh to give people options no to go
on the pie that Christie made she
wouldn't she had ready Whip and Cool
Whip well I had to she worked all day
her and Lando worked all day on their
pies what you do while they were working
had an entry I took a nap and then I
woke up and I said you know what
I'll go to Ralph's and get the ready
whip you don't you don't have to do that
you've worked so hard on this pie all
day I'm going to swoop over and get the
ready Whip and then I was like you know
what maybe I should get cool whip that's
the original oh you got it just in case
that's a smart smart thing when you've
done nothing to contribute to the item
itself and you've been sent to the store
just go Bonkers with options you don't
want to be the guy that leaves anybody
hanging
right and um Christy made a a chocolate
chest pie mhm which
was a Southern
Specialty she made this before before
she had never made it before it was not
a signature of hers if you eat it Gus's
Fried Chicken here in town which I
highly recommend they have like this
amazing chocolate chest pie and do you
know what makes it a chess
pie um because I just it I just call it
chocolate pie and then people say it's a
chocolate chest pie and I'm like am I
supposed to be it is different like with
it no I don't think it has anything to
do with the game the top of the pie gets
a
little turns into ack the chocolate gets
a little harder like chess gets harder
when you actually try to play it okay
the top of the chocolate as opposed to a
chocolate
pie in my mind is just chocolate pie
with mering on top no crust on top well
no there's no crust on top of a
chocolate chest pie am I not describing
this well oh it's crusty it it gets a
little harder it's almost as if it's
been fled a little bit Yeah Yeah and um
tastes good that's all I know oh gosh it
tastes so good and then Lando made a
apple pie with a bacon cheddar crust oh
so this is what category is that in
right this is cross category I noticed
that he entered it into the
Savory which was a brilliant idea but
because there were only three other pies
in Savory oh very smart shephard's pie
and then there was his pie and then
there was um some sort of a asparagus
kiche thing it was a risky move to go to
the Savory category I think it was the
right move y but I think that if I'm
voting in that and I get to the apple
pie I'm kind of like ah is this a is
this within the category and so then I'm
like hesitant to put it first right so
you probably got second place in that
and um Christy had a lot more
competition in this in the suite there
was all types of pumpkin pie there was
there was even a a um a pumpkin flavored
cheesecake and cheesecake cake okay Pie
cheesec as long as it ends with pie yeah
what makes a pie pie well it was
cheesecake which is a pie
yeah um there was no
other apple pie even in the sweet so I
think he would have been all right okay
that's but there was also no other
chocolate pie besides the one that
Christy made no chocolate pie and the
how many pies are we talking uh I would
say there
was
11 there were like 18 pies total but but
and four of them were Savory so that
leaves four any healthy pies no cuz you
know that just got to be honest with you
sometimes that happens in Los Angeles
right and I I I venture to say that
anytime a southerner enters into a
cooking contest of any kind in the Los
Angeles area they come in with a super
high Advantage because they're willing
to put butter butter sugar anything that
can cause a heart attack on the spot
before bedar we're totally willing to do
it without reservation that's right and
so we come in with a distinct Advantage
maybe midwesterners are like right
behind us on that I don't want to you
know shout out to the Midwest you guys
know how to put butter and something too
but not quite like we do in the South
I'm going to tell you what happened at
this party and then I want to open it up
a little bit to just talk about it the
nature of it as a party
okay um everybody was eating and it's
fun because you take like this little
sliver of pie you take like the smallest
slice you can get because you want to
taste 18 pies right and that's so much
fun to just get a little sliver pie and
then go over here and get another sliver
pie you're like remaking a pie on your
plate how many sers of other pies did
you guys bring one pie per one pie entry
yeah wow that's a thin and how many
people at the
party um I would say there was there
might have been
22 okay wow so we're talking little
slices and you can't probably more no
seconds there were
kids yeah not everybody did every pie
not everybody did every pie not
everybody was fully committed yep I I I
honestly didn't taste every single p
there were a few that I knew that you
just knew you would like it weren't
vying for my vote because you did vote
in the sweet category you would like
write your number down and you'd put it
in
that cup and then You' have you'd put
your other vote in the Savory cup and I
pulled the host aside and I said now I'm
gonna help you out here I don't know how
you did this Pie Contest before christe
and I came to the neighborhood this is
pre pandemic but now that we're here I
have a little if if I may I'd like to
help you out I'd like to help produce
yeah the this seems about right the
results of this P now what I didn't say
was I'm going to host the the reading of
the votes or anything that's that's your
thing I'm going to be your Apprentice is
what I told her and I said whenever it's
time to tally the results we just we
need to go we need to we need to
sequester ourselves to with the votes
and I'll tell you what we need to do you
know this is a price Waterhouse Coopers
type thing you know okay where the guy
at the gr Grammys has the the suitcase
and it's the part of the Grammys that
nobody listens to where they're like
certifying the votes or something maybe
Oscars too and did you feel that this
advice was welcome yeah yeah yeah okay
um she was open to it she didn't know
quite what was going on and um so we go
back there and I'm like all right I'm
taking Sav you take T take sweet and
you're just going to lay out all the
votes and she and then stack all the
votes by were there any any rules about
not voting for your own family's pie no
well because what about people with a
lot of children that proba well you got
there's there's got to be a benefit to
having a lot of children and this is
this can be it right that like if you
work on a farm okay you know pie eating
contest or pie tasting contest and farm
work is the only reason to have a lot of
children pie eating and contest party
yeah I'm having trouble accepting that
even though I wasn't there because you
got pie eating and contest so close like
pie eating and then contest is so close
to each other right that if you say it
too fast or I've had a couple of drinks
right next thing you know I'm eating all
the pie thinking that that's what we're
doing that's why you weren't invited
yeah right so I'm just saying um so yeah
I was like and then when it okay she was
like now we know who's in contention for
this thing in both categories and you
need to pick up a straggler vote here a
straggler vote there and then when and
then you need to pick up the top vote
the second vote getter top vote getter
and you need to engineer the order with
which you are revealing the answer I've
watched enough Survivor to know that
there is a best way to do this so I got
her to do it and then I did it for the
Savory and I gave him and we put him
back in the cup because you wanted to do
a live vote count fa up live yeah
because what I had heard was that in the
prepandemic version of the party that we
weren't invited to cuz we weren't
friends with these people at the time
they just said well the winner is so and
so and I was like come on come on we got
to make they even do third place second
place kind of thing nope nope nope um
and I don't believe in
that second place is the is the first
loser oh
okay so we went out there and um I
started playing some dramatic music were
you DJing this party I was playing some
music yeah they let me control the music
at their house okay wasn't at my house
so uh just so I can just understand the
complete setting here yeah um at what
point when you showed up did you take
over the music well he wasn't playing
music and you know he knows that I like
to play music he was like what music
should we play okay so he invited this
and I made a couple of suggestions and
then he was like hooking up to his
Bluetooth and I was like you just want
me
to do it okay and I and I gave him the
he could have said no but he said yes
and then I use that to my advantage when
right it was time I like I play some
dramatic music and I got everybody's
attention and then I introduced Tara the
host and um in both senses of the word
and then she comes out with the two cups
now this feels like a lot of added
pressure for her because she probably
wasn't expecting she was like we're
going to do it the way we've always done
it I'm going to read the person she was
totally but she was ready she was
totally onard willing okay yep yep she
passed test friendship like I mean these
people are are are good friends of ours
it's like I would you
know with a great idea like this if you
pitch it to somebody and they're like
well I don't want to it's like okay yeah
we're not friends anymore I mean it's
just like that's a risky willing to take
well I we're at that point in our
friendship honestly you know you knew it
would be well received yeah I knew it'
be well received but it's also like um
you know that's part of what makes
friendship fun is being willing to step
up and be a be a host push the limit a
little bit Yeah Yeah test test the
Friendship yeah yeah she did a great job
you know and everybody was super into it
and what could have been like just an
announcement that lasted a second and
then everyone was cheering and it was
over maybe a couple of pictures were
taken this is a dramatic reading of
votes the first vote goes to piie number
12 who's pie number 12 and then oh
everybody's looking at P the person with
pie number 12 and then we're like okay
um this is the shepherd's pie who is
that and it was the it was the father in
the back and then oh and now we've got
this one who is this and it was Lando so
the Savory came down to she would
read one of the guy with the shepherd's
pie and then she'd read one that was
Lando's pie okay and it kept going back
and forth between these two everybody
was so into it so the so the sort of the
opposite uh or like one thing one cave
got to this technique is that the
persons P who got no votes or very
little votes we now know exactly how
many votes they didn't get right exactly
so like we don't only know who first we
know who's last yep if you want to think
about it and who got zero votes right so
I'm assuming that somebody in the Savory
got zero votes and that person uh one
vote one vote yep okay so even better
because they got identified with the pie
publicly and then we've made sure that
they got no more votes mentioned right
and you remember that next time you
participate okay yeah because shame is a
good motivator sometimes there you go to
make better pies there you go did uh how
did that person respond and what was
their
pie was it the kich it actually it was
another one that I don't even remember
it was a brown pie you're saying it lost
to kich yeah
wow okay all right and um I don't know
what to say about that it came down to
it you're losing to kich in a Pie
Contest Lando actually won he did yeah
he did he paid off his uh his decision
to go into Savory and I said he beat
shephard's pie shepherd's pie didn't
have any Garden peas in it oh it didn't
have he he went pess oh you can't go PE
and that's what I was telling everybody
I was like listen you can't vote for
this there's no peas in the pot and the
wife was like well I you know I told him
I think he could go pis I was like well
that was your mistake yeah that's not a
shepherd's pie that's somebody else's
pie right I don't know whose it is
exactly but a Shepherd ain't going to
touch that with a 10- foot hook whatever
they have staff staff yeah yeah so and I
yeah I I was basically doing a smear
campaign
against this shepherd's pie beforehand
because I was trying to help Lando wi of
course I didn't tell anybody that
Lando's was the other pie oh so you were
saying what do you think about the Pea
shepherd's pie yeah I just kind of
it campaign so if it's not have peas in
it it's just got meat and potatoes in it
and carrots oh you went you got you
could do carrots and not Peas I know you
got to have peas to the carrots was a
whole it was a whole like sule of carrot
like it wasn't pieces of carrot it was
like a whole it was ground it it was a
layer puree P puree it was a carrot
layer it was very good but it it needed
some green it needed some green yeah and
of course he added the pie crust because
he was like I think I'd be disqualified
if I didn't put it in a pie crust yeah
which I you're right about that so he
got so close but he lost to my son and
then we move on to the suite M and it
came down to Christy's chocolate pie and
then the wife of the husband with the no
Peas the one who said no peas well this
is a pie family she had a
Frozen um what's that Tangy green pie a
key lime pie key lime one of your
favorites it might be the best kind of
pie but it was frozen is on purpose you
can get a key lime to the top of a Pie
Contest that's a good key lime because
key lime can be a little bit polarizing
yeah I didn't love it and of course I
was lobbying hard against it I was like
it's so Frozen it's so green okay yeah I
mean first of all I think you did a
couple of good things here I think you I
think ultimately you made this from what
I can tell I mean hearing it from you
you made this a better experience than
it would have been otherwise I did I do
take issue with the way that you got
yourself involved in trying to sway the
vote so right so I feel like you've
disqualified yourself from ever being
like a a polling station worker or
anything like that because you just
can't you can't be telling people and
this guy this guy never pees you know I
don't know what the the political
equivalent of not putting PE peas into
your pie is a smear you know chrisy got
second place and so it really came down
to these two families yeah it came down
to these two families which we ha each
other now well it feels like that's the
real story here is two pie family she
said if I would have voted for myself I
would have won she didn't vote for her
or it would have been tied I guess why
didn't she vote for her exactly that's
what I said you got to vote for she
should have said it in the did she vote
for someone else I was like yes she
voted for someone else I was like did
you think your pie was the best she was
like well yeah I just didn't feel like I
you don't even have to think your pie is
the best to vote for it I'm sure you
know what brown pie voted for themselves
that's where there one pocket one boat
came from I like it I like the brown P
was very good I made
it brown you know Brown pie voted for
brown pie why else would there be a vote
and there was so many votes it was going
back and forth but it was very dramatic
you know and then I you know I I hit
into some We Are the Champions they took
some photos and then it was then it was
just just basking in the glory of
everybody having pie there's no real
losers at a pie eating and contest party
okay we got to other than we got to work
on the name it's a great idea for a
party you're right about that everybody
bring a pie it's a contest that nobody
really
loses and it within the category of pie
you've got a meal and you've got a
dessert and I we were telling him dude
thank you for bringing the shepherd's
pie you kind of saved us cuz you
actually gave us dinner I just don't
think there was enough savy pies I think
that we got to work on that yep you I
think some people got to step I think
next year more people will step up to
Savory because uh there's more
opportunity to take especially if people
are not eating dinner I mean come on
give us some Savory stuff but this a
good idea for a party well first of all
I love themed parties and I know you do
and we've been talking about how I want
to start doing more of these Y at my
house to like be replace game night
which we had for Years everybody
everybody brings a pie there's I don't
think I can take this specific idea
though I don't know if I can take Pie
Contest the only overlapping friends is
me and Christie I don't think you can't
go to two pie you can't go to two Pie
Contest in a year I well I think
christiny and Lando might be like going
into the pi circuit so this would just
be stop number two of just winning pie
eating and contest parties all around
town you know well I mean I'm having
trouble coming up with another thing
better than piie because
that goes across Savory and sweet that
everybody can it can have freedom of
expression and and because it's not it's
a canvas it's not like everybody make
the best canoli or something and then
you're just I've eaten so many canoli
you know it's basically the same thing
oh this guy put peas in his canoli like
the key just goes to show you how far it
can go you know I wouldn't have put
asparagus in it but it wasn't my pie
yeah I do I mean we went to a party I
remember early
on being out here and it was the chili
eating it was a chili contest yep which
is that happens a lot that's that's fun
chili the chili contest is is fun
because yeah you know and again you're
going to have some dessert that's not
part of the contest but you're going to
eat a lot of different chili and you can
you can eat 20 different chilies so it's
a it's a close second you you know
something that was floated around in our
friend group but we never really nailed
it we never actually did it and there
was a lot there's a ground swell of
support for this and we never followed
through with it casserole night remember
that remember the talk of that yeah a
casserole party
cuz casseres are
like it can be pretty bad it's pretty
close to a pie I don't think it's close
to a pie but it's more on the Savory
side like I would venture to Guess that
you could unlock a whole type of savory
pie by just put a casserole in a pie
container but there's a lot of crossover
to go the other way to have a casserole
party I don't know if are there sweet
casseroles there can be I mean like if
you put monkey bread or a sheet cake is
a C is in I feel like we're getting into
a hot dog is a sandwich territory here
no that but but
like if you had like monkey bread in a
in a in a casserole dish as long as it's
contained in a casserole dish there's
lots of desserts that are casserole dish
yeah yeah there's probably a whole bunch
of stuff we're not thinking about right
now you can why don't you take that one
uh casserole we got to come up with a
good name
though um people should after everyone
gets there you like have the casserole
call yeah yeah yeah yeah um but there's
got to be a play on words with casserole
in CER
Rolan no casser
rollers
um we we'll come up with it casserole
eating and contest yeah there you go
that was it that was what it was on the
tip of my tongue yeah so that that was
that was it for me that's how I kicked
off my last weekend and then like
Saturday and Sunday was just
recovering just lots of naps and
thinking about the pies even though you
did say you were napping while the pies
were being made
yeah um okay I'm going to tell you about
something unexpected that happened to me
this weekend um but first we're going to
tell you about uh cotton candy Randy
Santa Claus hoodie it's cotton candy
Randy Warhol as Santa Claus we had a
t-shirt but now we have a hoodie so just
in time for the holidays commemorate it
at mythical.com with that hoodie all
right here has brought to you by better
help this time of year can be a lot for
a lot of people right you're wrapping up
the year you're going to be seeing
family you're thinking about oh another
year what's going to be different next
year and that transition something
coming to an end and something new
beginning sometimes it can be exciting
but sometimes it can be um a little
anxiety inducing sometimes sadness can
set in yeah it can be a lot and it's
natural to feel some sadness or anx
xiety about it but therapy can be a
bright spot amid all of the stress and
change something to look forward to to
make you feel grounded and to give you
the tools to manage everything going on
we're huge advocates for therapy and
want it to be accessible to everyone so
if you're thinking of giving it a try
start with better help it's entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get match with a licensed therapist and
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge find your bright spot
this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com earbiscuits is supported by chime
I'm throwing some gifts on my credit
card you know it's that time to get some
gifts put them on your credit card yeah
sure is I'm setting you up to talk about
it Noel no matter what you're buying
this season link when you use the
secured chime credit Builder Visa credit
card you can build your credit score
with on Time payments for everyday
purchases plus there's no annual fee
interest or credit check to get started
use it everywhere Visa credit cards are
accepted and build credit using your own
money and with a chime checking account
you can get paid up to 2 days early and
with direct deposit when you set up that
direct deposit sign up for spot me and
chime will spot you up to your limit
when you make a debit card purchase or
cash withdrawal that exceeds your
balance chime also gives you access to
over 60,000 fee free ATMs easily found
on the app start building your credit
open a chime checking account with at
least $200 qualifying direct deposit to
get started get started at chime.com
that's chime.com the chime credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
stride bankna member FDIC out of network
ATM withdrawal fees May apply call
8442446363 for details late payment May
negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary Early Access to direct
deposit funds depends on payers bot me
eligibility requirements and overdraft
limit
Supply um
so as is not uncommon the weekend rolls
around yeah and we just haven't just
haven't made plans I'll I'll be honest
with you I really enjoy just kind of
being at home yeah you know like Ving
out giving yourself permission to We
were supposed to go out with some
friends on Friday night but uh Friday
I started feeling the tingle of a sore
throat oh you backed out and then in the
afternoon I started well I had a
headache on Thursday night I remember
telling you that Thursday night headache
yeah and then like you kind of feel your
eyes sort of like something starts
happening to your eyes at least this is
what happens to me like I'm like is this
an allergy it could have just been
allergies I think it's called
introversion but it it no I know I enjoy
hanging out with people but I started
feeling myself get sick and so we kind
of pulled the plug on
it was it was a last minute dinner that
had been planned the night before so it
wasn't like oh we've been waiting to see
you know it was friends that we see I
bet you I bet you they were relieved too
and um so but then you know I rebounded
because first of all I went to bed at
9:30 which is your bedtime there you go
on a Friday night damn I slept for like
11 hours or something it was just a full
reset I woke up a million bucks and uh
well you made the right call then
and Jesse was like well you want to do
something tonight and I was like yeah
but sometimes in this is we
are spoiled in a in being in a big city
because there's always something going
on but sometimes you just feel like well
you want to go eat dinner you want to go
to a movie you still kind of default to
these very common things that people do
right because a lot of things like yeah
oh I want to go to a museum or something
they all close at like 5:00 p.m. and if
if you didn't make plans it's you know
what I'm saying like a lot of stuff
closes I'm talking about the night time
what are you do in the night time we
don't go to we're not Club people we
don't Club no you're
not and Jesse is
like
um vulture
Fest like the online magazine vulture
she's like oh there's lots of
interesting things happening in it
vulture Fest okay I mean this is the
kind of thing that we might go to that
like it like comes through uh like a PR
related thing like oh make an appearance
at vulture you want to go to this and so
I we don't typically do this kind of
thing this is starting to make sense
Lincoln you know you said that you
learned from Jesse who taught to chrisy
what we were doing over the weekend well
I got a text from Lincoln asking about a
party that you went to and he wanted to
know if I was there he all of a sudden
Lincoln off at College very interested
in in your weekend so You' succeeded at
peing the interest of the collegan
minded boy H Ma you know man
guy yes you're
some which will make sense in a second
um so I've actually I I think I've
actually recommended this particular guy
on the podcast many years ago uh Brian
Jordan Alvarez is an
actor and he had a bunch of like
really in not like really well produced
YouTube sketches back in the day that I
found very funny like he was really
throwing himself into a YouTube sketch
okay and we watched a couple of them you
would remember if I showed them to you
and like it's very funny and then he's
gone on to you know he was like he was
on willing like the reboot of willing
Grace and he uh was in that Megan he was
in the movie that we watched at my
birthday party the Megan movie He plays
like oh really the assistant to the
person the woman developing the the
robot he's in a a number of scenes okay
not like a starring role but
um again don't tell me how it ended
because I don't want you to spoil it did
you walk out no I just don't remember oh
um about say I I remember you being in
the hot tub the whole time so so that's
the last thing I remember too I didn't
remember you get up so he has he did
this thing during the pandemic where of
course you know he wasn't really working
as much where he's this incredible
character actor and can do all these
different voices and he created this guy
called TJ Mack and I'm just gonna play
like the I think this might be the
original video with the with the filter
face he puts a filter face on it and uh
and this is and Lincoln loves this guy
and like talks Jess out he's created a
whole universe of multiple characters
yeah but the main two characters are
this guy TJ Ma and then TJ Ma's wife
so this is the introductory
video so yesterday I go to the TJ Mark
and this is the first time I'm finding
this place available in my city and I
see all the deal I see a Gucci underwear
see Calvin Klein
underwear and I say I've never been able
to buy this for
$30 so I go to different col they tell
me actually this is half off it's not
even 30 is $15 for three pair of Calvin
CL on you ever heard of a better deal
than that so I'm going to go to Marshall
tomorrow okay that's it so and so he he
started to be known as TJ ma because
that's how he say TJ Ma and then but
he's got like the wife he's got the wife
is played by him he plays everybody and
sometimes he uses a filter but then he
also has like this Rich Southern
Mom oh my God which is just him in a wig
but then he has an Australian like w
weightlifter he has this exchange
student and there's these ongoing
stories for each one like hundreds of
videos depending on the character I love
it um and and just so just so you know
like
uh because people might be like oh he's
using this accent like I didn't meet but
I saw his mother uh at this event and
his mother kind of talks like TJ Ma so
this is like he's getting these accents
from his like this is his family this is
his background okay if there's any
question about that okay all right Mama
Alvarez sounds like that so but okay so
then he does this thing where he starts
he just start he's improving all this
stuff he improves this
song that's about sitting play that for
you the OPP
stand the opp running around sitting is
a wonderful thing to do because you sit
him see the oppos standing on your head
sit the oppos hanging from a bar sit is
a wonderful thing to do I got one thing
to say I think the C is something the
people say it is bad but you know the
sitting is actually good because you
deserve to relax it's kind of like a nap
it's kind of like something else but it
is actually just sitting sitting the
opposite
okay okay
okay he he very clearly just puts the
filter on and just like go great so that
so he's been getting popular for this
but this one in particular like if you
just go on Tik Tok and if if you know
you know and I'm we're late to the party
if you know right but like this guy and
that song got redone by so many people
there were like you know that you see
those videos where it's like a chorus
teacher with like a big room of people
in there they sing they sing that song
like that's yeah all these professional
musicians like remaking it and then like
this guy did this version of
[Music]
it sitting is a wonderful thing to do
because you
sit okay so many remixes how many views
that only has6 this is just this is on
YouTube on Tik Tok this has millions I'm
just this is just the YouTube clip that
came up I love that and then and now
he's like writing his own like first of
all hey they had him on like he was in t
like Time Magazine brought him to like
the headquarters and he did this whole
thing and he's been on a couple of
morning shows and okay uh he's just
constantly talking about this and now
he's writing songs that are like really
well produced and but still very very
funny like you would you know how
sometimes people find something and they
get popular for something and then they
just like like the guy who made that
video uh a few months ago there was this
thing going around and it was just like
uh omage to like Euro pop music and it
was a guy and a girl and it went really
big and then the guy kept trying to redo
it and it got cringier and cringier each
time that's not what Brian is doing good
what he's doing is he's like so
naturally funny and he knows why these
things are funny he hasn't had one as
big as sitting again well anyway
opposite back to vulture Fest Jess's
like Brian Jordan Alvarez in
conversation with TJ Mack and his wife
what
live and I was like yes I want to go to
that it was like 4:30 in the afternoon
on a SAT you were sitting at the time
and I was like yes I want to go to that
you know we never take advantage of all
these things that happen in the city and
I and and then we started looking at the
other things that were happening all
these things were sold out Weird Al had
something that he was doing right after
it and then those the please don't don't
destroy guys the the three guys that got
picked up by SNL the sketch guys from
YouTube like they've got a new movie uh
that's got Conan in
it there there was a special screening
of that I was like let's go to they were
all sold out everything else was sold
out but this was not sold out you had to
buy an individual ticket individual
ticket was like 17 bucks and we go to
the we go to this thing and you know
it's like it's like down there at the uh
NY Studios in Hollywood we've been to
something there before so there's kind
of like this grassy fake grass area
where there's like some vendors um shout
out
to Holy Grail Donuts I think it is well
I'll confirm that just make sure that's
right uh fans who came up and gave me
and Jesse some free
donuts uh they're they're fans of the
show and you know some like vendor
selling stuff and you know drink tickets
and that kind of thing I'm like oh we're
like at a festival like we never do this
just as authentic just people in Los
Angeles and then we go into were the
were you were you fitting in with the
demo oh yeah okay yeah yeah well what
did you expect I mean I was probably
older than most people if that's what
you're asking well when you said like
weird I was there pleased it's not it
wasn't just a Tik Tock no no it was very
much sort of like a curation of things
that are actually funny okay as as
determined by the LA crowd you know what
I mean like that which is a good place
to be um okay uh I mean they're not
going to call me and you if that's what
you're asking I mean I think we're funny
but I'm just saying I think we're funny
but you know what I'm saying need to use
those Tik Tok filters so uh we go in
there and sit down and it's like 150
people yeah and I'll show you a video of
what he did and because this is the
first time he's ever done this this this
is what I posted on my my story but he
was
on he was on
stage he's just facing the other way
doing
it he's just facing the other
way so he's got he's projecting his
phone onto the thing behind it yes and
you know and then he's got like uh let's
see this is like this to encourage this
is exchange student just be in a
stage okay so and he's taking sound of
like he was doing a good job he's taking
questions from the audience and so it's
all impromptu and and there's and he's
always his back is always to the
audience he came out and he sits down
with the moderator cuz he didn't he
didn't by the way he didn't have to face
away from the audience yes he did
because it was the right choice it was
the right choice but he didn't have to
for technical reasons he did it for
comedic reason because you don't want to
see well so he comes out cuz his phone's
captured and he's looking at his phone
he's not looking at the screen but okay
so he comes out he sits down as Brian
with the moderator and the bit is that
he's the manager of TJ Ma and and
everyone okay um he's been kind of
working with with them and he's doing a
super tongue-in-cheek right and he's
kind of explaining like we we haven't
done this before or whatever right and
he's like oh he's ready he's backstage
he's ready to go and so he leaves and
then he then he takes his phone and then
he comes out with his phone facing the
other way and then people the crowd of
people who were there were so they're
like me and Jesse people who just sit
there together in bed and watch right
him do all these characters right yeah
and the Joy on people's faces it just
makes me so happy to watch this it was
so Niche even though he's gotten really
popular like he's it's so like
sidesplitting funny and then he starts
singing the songs and everybody knows
the words yeah and then he's like I'm
you want to talk to my wife and like he
brings the wife out and and they're like
and he was like you want to talk to
anybody else and they're like exchange
student and so he leaves and he comes
back and some of them he has wigs on and
some of them he doesn't it's just a
filter and then there's one that he
comes back out and he's about to do it
and he realizes that it's a voice filter
he's like oh I realized I can't do that
because this one requires a voice filter
he says Ah let me see if I can do it
anyway and he like made a joke about how
he was really horse so it's like an hour
the whole show yeah yeah and so he was
like listen this is the first time and
then kind of act and he's like this is
the first time done this DM me and let
me know if you have any feedback you
know cuz he's like workshopping this
thing to see and people are like what do
you think about the fact that this is
the thing that you've gotten really
popular for when you've got this serious
acting career and he was like I love the
fact that this is the thing that I've
gotten popular for this is you know
Wonderful that's great anyway um I don't
know I believe in this internet thing
and this is the reason why well it was
funny because it one of the things that
it happened for me was
I was
like oh not this is what it must feel
like if you if you're a big fan of like
G mythical
morning as an example and then you go to
a live show and we do something that
only the people who are in this world
this mythical world can really
appreciate it yeah and you and like I
haven't been in a sit in a Sit I've been
to concerts and stuff like that but
being in a thing where it's just like oh
yeah everybody knows why this is this
thing is funny and this is something
that I can tell my friends about and
they might know about it but they
probably don't mhm um there's a good
feeling it made me think ah we need to
do that again yeah it's um I think it's
it's good to be on to experience that
from the other side because like we're
like we've talked about before it's like
we weren't like we're not really
contributing members of
fandoms right you know so we don't we
don't have the community the online
community interactive experience that
like you actually you actually found
yourself a part of you going to join his
fan club you GNA you did you DM him I do
want to DM him to tell him I think this
is your version what I what I thought
about it but I kind of just did I I have
I have some ideas for like how because
he was you know first of all I love the
facing away from the crowd because
you're seeing it and he's like dancing
and you're like that's the guy doing it
but I'm interacting with this screen and
then there's a couple of times where he
the character sees himself on the screen
and kind of looks at himself and smiles
he was discovering all this in the
moment because he's very quick like that
um but I have a few ideas for for like
you know how to make how to blow it up
even bigger okay you want to no I'm just
you DM I'll DM him okay Lincoln was
impressed man linol was impressed well
the well the thing Jesse and I said as
we left it it's like he's got that
inside joke with his with
they into it yeah like he he was like me
and this guy were like really close
friends now because we always use this
guy's voice when we talk to each other
okay yeah you know it's like that's why
I said your Som because that's what he
talks about his wife and
Som um but the thing I told Jesse I was
like listen I'm not great at planning
doing things but we live in a place
where there's always something to do and
I'm always I I'm going to you if you
plan it I'm going to be up for it
because you know we met we met some
people met there was a number of GMM
fans that that I met but I connected
with them not as them being a fan of GMM
but them being a fan of this thing that
we're both fans of and that was a cool
way to connect with people versus just
somebody who's just a fan of what we do
yeah and I was like oh this is oh this
is a cool way to meet people people of
common interest I know it sounds it
sounds it's ridiculous but I'm just
saying if like if you you if you go
to um because it was more Niche than
like going to a concert like oh yeah we
all love Jason isol yeah okay yeah all
15,000 of us here the Greek or whatever
is different yeah than the than this
thing I want to let's talk about this
this AI pin thing okay you want to talk
about it I want to talk about it because
you teased it and
um I don't know what think about it
what's it called uh it's called the AI
pen that's by Humane is the company so
you probably have heard about this thing
it looks like an like an iPod Shuffle
that's just attached to your hoodie or
wherever you want to put wherever youd
want to like pin an iPod Shuffle on your
person it looks like that and if you
have the time and kind of like a little
miniature calculator with no button
almost look like a miniature like scale
that you would step on yeah it's like a
it's like a weight scale um if you had
the time I would encourage you to go and
watch the like 10minute presentation
that this company put together for the
thing
because um it's strange it is so strange
it's the way that they chose to about
doing it I guess it's like a the
creators or Creator in like a for like
marketing executive or some sort of
typee of executive and it's like and
there's no pumping circumstance to it
it's it's almost like a rehearsal for
how to talk about it it's very low
energy very low energy but in like a
mesmerizing way that you're like and I
again those things definitely not trying
too hard I don't know if this was
intentional I don't know if they're like
lulling lulling me into
something I mean at one point I was
wondering if they were
AI I wonder if AI wrote the script but
the idea behind this thing just in
general is that this is supposed to
replace your phone right so it is this
little pen that you can interact with
via voice but also IT projects a
laser sort of interface onto your hand
just like a little projector like if you
could imagine it was a little projector
and like very like just a few colors not
I guess they could probably do video but
everything was sort of like a digital
display of a clock or whatever it was
like monochromatic it was blue blue text
yeah on your hand and then while it's on
your hand you make these little gestures
to like oh if you're listening to music
you can like change the volume or go to
the next track or you can do little
things with your fingers to like change
what app you are accessing because it's
all these like integrated it's not
really apps it's just kind of all inte
AI That's using it's using AI as a
platform for you to be able to access
all kinds of information to be like hold
a book up in front of it and it's like
oh where can I get this book on how much
is this book online $28 buy this book
and it'll just buy it right I mean
there's nothing from the demonstration
that
really shook me up that was like oh this
is this is amazing but what was the one
thing we were like oh we could use that
it was more of like a business like
keeping was it keeping notes I can't
remember there was one part where we
perked up oh it was tell me what Give me
a summary of my emails oh oh yeah yeah
and you know or a summary of my texts or
or whatever yeah give me a summary of
everything from my inbox basically and
it was as if someone had read your
entire inbox and they just said well
Jimmy sent in the proposal and
Tammy uh followed up with opportunities
for
your dinner Mar wants to get sushi or
whatever and it's so it was it was like
you an assistant just kind of taking you
through your day just kind of combing
through all of the crap that people sent
you like
overnight that would that seemed pretty
smart and I'm I really like the idea of
like I said I'm I'm getting rid of like
having a laptop or ever typing I like
the idea of getting rid of a phone
entirely too getting of a screen but I
don't know about this getting rid of the
screen and then I've got the screen on
my hand as a
projection uh well and I think this is
where the the question of what actually
can you do with well there's a number of
things running into my mind first of
all I have to imagine that the general
response is negative right I I just
think that we're in a we're in a part
we're in a phase right now where I mean
first of all like they couldn't get
those uh glasses not the Google Glasses
but more more recently The Meta glasses
that are like the Rayban meta
partnership which is like a cool looking
pair of glasses but it's like a video
camera yeah and the main reason is
privacy right that's the main thing
people have have responded to is this is
a privacy issue because you're
constantly recording everything and it
says that you're not it's not constantly
listening like a Siri or a Alexa but if
it's voice activated it has to be at
least somewhat listening I mean how
could you do voice activated if it
wasn't listening I don't know it's got
to be listening and then it to me it is
like a wearable it's like a body cam
Siri plus a body Cam and but and then
whenever you interact with it it is
depending on your task it's it's
interfacing
with a certain like the version of AI
that is most pertinent to help is is is
what I was under the impression it's not
just like okay it only interacts with
chat GPT I think it uses chat GPT as its
framework but chat GPT with the right
plugins can go into all kinds of
applications I think the most
significant part of this is that right
because if you think about what happened
with chat
GPT um the average person of course knew
about it right and maybe the average
person maybe not the average person like
the slightly more interested person
actually signed up for it and like used
it right I'm in that category like I
have chat GPT I've used it for a number
of things to summarize text I've asked
it I've asked it different questions
that I could probably have just done a
Google search on but it's not a but I
haven't done the thing it's not been
convenient enough for me to do that it
hasn't gone the next step to be
integrated into these other things right
and the thing about unless the interface
is severely simplified and people don't
have to think about it and make these
connections themselves it'll never
actually be integrated into society so
this is like an effort to be like hey
you're not really thinking about how
this is working you're just asking it
questions and showing it things telling
it to remember things and then it's
supposed to also oh you're in this part
of town I know you like this kind of
food oh you're you're you're 200 yards
from that sushi place you like and it's
that time of day you haven't had lunch
yet because another thing they show on
the video is it like telling it like he
holds up almonds in front of it and it's
like how much protein is in this and
it's like 12 grams right you know so but
so there's definitely this
dystopian weirdness that I think people
are going to be super wary of right but
is it just inevitable is it is it
inevitable that it's all going to get
integrated in some way or are we just
gonna basically be like no we don't we
don't want that to be what being a human
is it's it's inevitable it's gonna you
know anything that makes life easier and
more convenient it'll just creep in and
then you'll you it I
mean look at how many people are
involved in online banking you know it's
like when we were coming up in in
college and you started like well
logging putting your bank account
information into a website and like
looking at your Banking online and God
forbid getting so like all someone needs
is your password and they can take all
your money like we definitely set yeah
so all of that stuff there's a high
level of trust now because of the
convenience factor the thing that's
getting me is okay they're like first a
market to
introduce like an an electronic
assistant that connects with connects
with AI but like the series and the
alexas of the world are going to start
interfacing with not just the internet
at large but
using via AI tools I mean it's hard to
imag happening more and more every week
it's OBS anything about
this that would be a true phone
replacement like that's the that's the
part that I have a difficult time
because people are going to want that
screen they want the screen because the
screen can give you this high
quality
video
interface that
I mean I like the I like not having
those interfaces I would like to have
less screen in my life but if I can just
ask my phone these things and it can
send me updates I mean you've already
got the Apple watch you've got smartw
watches that are kind of doing the same
thing right an Apple Watch with the
right integrated AI how is it really
different it's the one thing it doesn't
have is it doesn't have a camera that's
recording what you're seeing which is
again this big sticking point which I
completely understand they said that
there they have a um like a a light that
comes on kind of like on any old
camcorder so if you see the red light
you know you're being recorded right so
it's a courtesy light but yeah I I was
watching a movie
um I don't know if it's a movie or TV
show I can't remember this past was
there only one of them and was it long
that's what I can't
remember but it was an it was older
woman and when I say uh oh no I know
what it was uh when I say older she was
older than the people she was
interacting with it was that
uh that Netflix Jennifer Lawrence movie
romantic comedy that is a little bit
awkward because hard feeling no hard
feelings yeah cuz she's like playing a
32y old oh you called Jenifer lawence an
old woman no no well that that's kind of
the joke of the movie She's 32 oh yeah
and she is in the movie she is I don't
know how she is in real life and she's
basically being paid by these parents
yeah to have sex with their 19-year-old
son to get him to come out of a show uh
questionable premise it's a little
uncomfortable admittedly I didn't really
understand that that was exactly what I
was getting myself into um so I don't
know whether or not I recommend it but
what I will say is there's a scene where
she's going into this party that's got a
bunch of you know 18 and 19 year olds
yeah
and she's doing some things that are
embarrassing and everyone is filming her
like everything that she says and
everything that she does somebody's got
a camera on
her which is kind of the way I mean
they're making fun of this Trope right
of Jin Z basically shooting everything
like something happens everybody breaks
their camera out I just is the Privacy
thing I know the Privacy thing is a
concern for people who are like our
age which basically is Gen X and I know
the Privacy thing is a little bit of a
concern for millennial
does jiny really care I mean
do that if the less and less so we see a
pattern because I mean and also it's
kind it seems to me I'm saying this as a
person in the US this privacy thing is a
big thing in the US but in a lot of
other places in the world I mean in
Europe you've got this CCTV like
everything you go outside and you're
basically on camera right and I'm not
making an assessment about whether it's
good or bad I'm just saying that but
they're living with that people just
don't care as much there seems to be
this inevitability that everything that
I do anytime I interact with a
person it's going to be
captured and it's kind of the way that
life is anyway I can make I SP you can
remember your your brain is remembering
it but you but the fact that it can be
completely uh broadcast to somebody else
but then if it can easily be faked if in
five years I can create a video of you
doing anything I want you to do that is
indistinguishable from a video of you
actually doing something what is the
point of the Privacy at that you know I
don't
know I just don't want to have to worry
about where I'm going to put this thing
on my
blouse you know it's like it really got
me when he started talking about like
and there's different clips different
types of clips and here's a really low
profile clip if you're wearing say a
silk blouse
I'm like what now I got I got to worry
about that it's like I think I'd rather
just have a a wristatch you know what
I'm saying like yeah I mean the silk
blouse shouldn't have brought that up
man that I'm out the point of the
putting it on the lapel seems to be the
field of view and the handsfree
interaction even though yeah I saw the
uh new commercial for the Apple watch
and now you can do this
yeah touch your finger
and you can assign that action yeah I
don't know what it's knows it knows that
you're touching your finger you can kind
of feel like the
haptic I'm not going to say what it's
feeling but it does it does pick up on
it I don't know it's this is it's an
interesting thing to talk about right
now because I feel
myself wanting to pull back a whole lot
from I just I you know I find myself
sometimes and I real I've been just
scrolling through Tik Tok I mean this is
I'm sure this is a relatable experience
and I'm like I I just gained nothing I
lost time I'm trying to pull back from
more like connection I don't do it that
often and and I still have like the
whenever I start looking at Tik
Tok it's the thing that gets me to stop
more than anything is just like it's
like coming to like what you are
hypnotized when you're doing you're and
then you're like what what have I gained
from this what am I looking for it's
like just
observing it's really the first time
that I've been pulled into it I don't
think it ever happened with with uh
Instagram until Instagram started
copying Tik Tok of course yeah and so
like I'm very late to this experience
but I'm like oh this is this is what
everybody talks about the
hypnotic I'm clearly looking for
something but I cannot articulate what
it is
but I'm very much searching for it like
I just can't I can't wait to find it and
it's it's very animalistic and so it's a
bit
disquieting it it's disturbing well it's
tapping into your your yeah I don't like
mean networks B and it just and I just
feel like I've just wasted oh there's 20
minutes yeah so I just don't know how
these this technology fits into that
I'm reminded of my resolution at the at
the top of the year it's like on my
phone less pet my dogs more like
whenever I'm sitting down except on the
toilet even when I'm on the damn toilet
Jasper's coming in there like clamoring
up my you don't lock the door I let him
in oh okay because I don't want him
peeing or pooping somewhere in the house
while you're doing it yeah like get any
ideas don't take any cue from me stay in
here with me so I can keep an eye on you
got to keep an eye on that little posum
all the time and so yeah he's I pet my
dogs pet my dogs more scroll less and I
think that there's I think that there is
definitely the
potential that we collectively rebel
against any further technological
integration right but here's the problem
with
that they'll be
what if we decide as a culture like
we're just like this is bad for us it
never happen we we can't take this I
mean we're already experienced when you
talk about that scrolling through Tik
Tok the reason that it's so hypnotic is
because we're just not made to interact
with that much we're not supposed to
know everything that's happening all
over the world right now everywhere like
our brains are not meant to take in that
much information to know the worst
things that are happening everywhere on
Earth I can just look into this little
window and I can find all of it like
your brain's not made for that so what
if we just decide like enough evidence
comes out that's like we we need to do
less of this we need to create an
environment that is more like the
environment that we come from and we
need to use technology to enhance our
lives but not just make everything super
convenient it'll be some sort of
government thing in in nor Norway but
the thing is the norian government we
we'll do it well what I'm getting at for
prisoners and Sweden well no we may
there's you never know what what's going
to happen we may collectively but then
there's going to be a certain percentage
of people who are like well we've got
all this technology and they're going to
become like superheroes do you know what
I mean they may have miserable lives but
they'll know everything that there is to
know at any given moment and we be like
is it going to create this like cultural
divide between the people who are tapped
in and the people who are tapped
out let's find out we'll be there for it
I do have a recommendation that is
somewhat related to this you know
sometimes you go down or or a Tik Tock
rabbit hole and you do get rewarded with
something and this is my wck baby wck
baby 1 two 3 4 this
week I I invite you to
search
um forest animals cozy
aesthetic and um I found this one series
of images I took a screenshot here here
so I can show it to you while my phone's
off um this is from somebody with a
bunch of emojis and the named Spence and
they they said this is so nostalgic it's
just forest
animals like cartoon images of forest
animals cozy in their dens but then
their dens are like it's like Wes
Anderson cutouts of trees and
underground layers but they're all like
it's like bears and raccoons like and F
is just like snuggled up in their human
beds with their human rugs and it's very
story
bookish but it's a very specific type of
nostalgia is it AI from our
childhood uh I don't think so cuz it
literally can easily be it's just oh
yeah it's just an it's an aesthe it's an
aesthetic that maybe people are
emulating illustrations of it now and
that make you happy so does that
hypnotize you it hypnotized me I saw
this and then I had this feeling of cozy
Nostalgia and then I went to sleep and I
didn't have I didn't have a sense of
coming to I had a sense of drifting off
into a story book Neverland did you
dream about being a bear inside of a
tree I don't remember maybe probably
forest animals cozy
aesthetic you're welcome
well never forget that you can join the
conversation with us using # earbiscuits
but you can also leave a message a
question an observation a contention at
1888 earpod one so let us know we'll
talk at you next
week hi so I am a teacher and I just
thought I'd share a fun story from my
day today we had a student catch a moth
in the hallway brought it into our
classroom and all of my boys reaction
they're in six grade so about 12y olds
was let's take our shoes off and throw
our shoes at the moth so I had about 15
boys launching their shoes all around
the room because that is how you take
care of a moth in the classroom to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of ear biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't for get
to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical
best